what are the pros and cons if any of
extreme minimalism so um are there other
pros or their cons or they're both in my
practice yes definitely yeah because I
just do what I love and the result is
extreme and I'm one of them yeah just
continuously doing that so any con the
benefits is happiness yes what are the
cons are there any cons to be very
technical I would say it takes a lot of
time yeah to figure it out yeah and
maybe I get tired of tapping into myself
and some days you know I'm not so in
tuned I'm not as mindful I'm not as a
calm so dealing with that part of myself
as well during the practice of extreme
minimalism that's the tough part yeah
well you know nothing in life worth
doing is easy so certainly it's gonna be
difficult to practice extreme minimalism
but you know if anything you're extreme
minimalism helps you deal with like the
imperfectness and that that is worth
putting in the effort for yeah yeah and
I mean if I just take the word extreme
out for a moment are the pros and cons
of minimalism yeah I think the pros
certainly outweigh the cons although I
will say that I think some people will
have more of a predisposition to be a
minimalist and others do I think
minimalism is is inherently useful to
everyone no not necessarily I think
there are quite a few people who are
completely contented by the status quo
and if you are really happy with the
status quo and you get really happy from
acute accumulating more items then Who
am I to say well that is the wrong way
of living however if you feel
discontented by the way that you've been
living
if you feel discontented especially by
the material possessions and the desire
for more that you're experiencing then
minimalism is is a great tool now the
con side of things is we dealt with a
question earlier today about well what
if you
I reached the goal of minimalism and now
I'm not happy or I've reached the goal
of minimalism now what'll I do the
biggest con is people mistake minimalism
as though it were an end result of
course minimalism is not the end result
though it is merely the path that'll
that'll lead you toward a more
meaningful life it is not in and of
itself a meaningful life and so we get
we often get confused thinking that this
blunt instrument is going to solve all
of our problems as soon as we get there
but you're not going to get there as
soon as you reach the horizon a new
horizon will appear
yeah athlean has a question for us Ryan
yeah yeah before we move on to
Kathleen's question I do want to say the
one con that I can think of is the
judgement that people will have the
ostensible judgement but here's the
thing though is I was talking to a
friend yesterday and they were talking
about how if you're living a life that
is 100% in alignment with your values
and beliefs if you're living your best
life people will want to assassinate you
and that's how you know you're doing it
well so it is a con but I'd rather have
you know people judging me rather than
going with the flow and being living a
life of discontent